hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning
spoilers ahead
today i'm gonna explain a 2019 japanese
drama movie called brave father online
our story of final fantasy xiv
the movie begins with akiowamoto a
japanese young man working at an
advertising agency playing final fantasy
games
he uses a girl avatar called matey and
has several online close friends the
next morning he is surprised to find his
mother has cooked fancy meals for him
and miki his sister's breakfast
she explains that the meals are intended
to celebrate their father's promotion to
a director at his company although both
akio and miki react coldly to it they
are confused because their father akira
would not deliver the good news himself
and is so busy working that he does not
seem to care for them
akio flashbacks to his childhood where
he remembered his dad as an all-serious
person and only cared about his work
arriving at work he meets his co-worker
yoshi who just comes back after he took
a break due to his father's funeral
yoshi tells him that he regrets not
knowing his father too much when he was
still alive
coming back home akio is surprised to
find his father has resigned from his
company just after he got promoted
without any reason and awkwardly helps
him unpack his office equipment
he goes to the bar with yoshi after work
hours and discusses his father's sudden
retirement yoshi suggests that his dad
may be having an affair with a client's
wife just like nishira a manager at
their office who looks like he resigned
with honor akio does not buy the idea he
thinks his dad would not do something
like that along the way home yoshi
suggests sakio get to know his dad
better as he cannot recall any facts
about his father now that he has passed
away
akio recalls his first game final
fantasy bought by his father and he was
so fascinated by it until now
his father used to accompany him to play
the game when he was little which seems
like the only good time he ever spent
with his father
in the game akio is gathering with his
friends and tells his concern about his
father he then gets the idea to invite
his father to play the game to get to
know him better which is friend support
the next day he gives his father a
retirement gift of playstation 4 in a
final fantasy 14 game
akira does not seem really interested in
the gift which disappoints akio so he
heads back upstairs to his room
turns out akira tries to install the ps4
console himself but does not know how to
do it so miki heads to akio's room to
ask him to help their father set the
game and create his avatar which he
named indie jones based on akio's
suggestion on superhero names akio then
goes back upstairs to go online so he
can observe his father's character from
afar although he is careful not to let
miki know that he plays the game too
after getting familiar with the game
akira challenges an enemy too difficult
for him so akio decides to help him by
defeating the enemy
akira wants to thank that other player
but does not know how to do it then akio
remembers that his dad does not have a
keyboard to type messages he delivers a
keyboard downstairs after miki asks for
his help again and comments that he
should talk more directly to their
father
back at the office yoshi tries to flirt
with women co-workers by offering them
candies but one of them satomi is
actually attracted to a keo and secretly
watches him
coming home akio learns that his father
quits playing final fantasy because he
does not know how to change outfits and
feels embarrassed for it
after teaching him and seeing that his
father is interested again in playing
the game he encourages himself to
directly talk to his father's character
in the game
he laughs at his father's very formal
responses but he seems to adjust himself
to sound less formal and expresses his
gratitude to akio for saving him earlier
akio sends him a friend request but then
is startled by a knock at his door
akira knocks on the door himself awkward
and confused because he just received a
friend request
akio says friends are good to have in
the game because they can help him
achieve more quests and beat difficult
enemies his father goes back to the
living room to continue playing and
accepts his friend's request then he
goes on an adventure with akio and his
online friends
he seems genuinely happy after defeating
an enemy a site new to miki and her
mother
he goes to the kitchen to refill his
drink then continues playing at almost
the same time akio goes downstairs to
refill his drink too
miki deduces that they both are playing
the same game simultaneously
at the office satomi secretly peaks at
akio's computer screen to find out that
he likes to play final fantasy and tries
to play the game herself to initiate a
conversation with him
meanwhile fumien the main client for
akio's advertising agency is rumored to
hire a competitor to work on their
advertising projects
akio's director tasks him and yoshi to
meet with them and persuade them to stay
partnered with their company however
nakajima fumien's new manager tells them
that family and plans to do something
new and exciting and cannot keep
repeating the same formula from akio's
company
luckily they give them a chance to
present an advertising proposal later
back at home akira is really invested in
the final fantasy game but gets
frustrated as he cannot defeat an enemy
named freit however akio patiently
assists him although he knows he has
work to do then they finally defeat a
freit after that he dares to tell his
struggle to akira as in final fantasy
his father only considers him as a
stranger
he tells him that defeating enemies
together in-game teaches him that he
should not give up when faced with tough
challenges
surprisingly akira advises that he
should pour love and enthusiasm into the
advertising presentation to attract
clients
he shares his point of view as a former
employee in a factory who has seen many
advertising campaigns akio then
researches the advertisements that
famine has seen and tries to find
insights on what fumian is interested in
which will form the basis of their
campaign proposal
akio and yoshi then present simple but
personal and touching stories for their
campaign on family and sochizuke product
akio ends their presentation by sharing
his personal story on how he once
studied late at night for his university
entrance exams then his dad cooked him
in ochsuk he knew his dad did not eat
late at night so he made that ochazuke
only for a son
that story really attracts for me ends
board so akio's company secures the deal
the whole office is happy for a kyo even
satomi offers to treat him
however akio wants to meet with satomi
in the game where they are then joined
by akira's avatar
so tomi almost spoils their real-life
connections but akio jumps in to prevent
his dad from finding out
akira tells that he is confused about
his distant and cold-acting son and is
disappointed about his daughter who does
not seem to care much about her future
he is even more furious that miki brings
her boyfriend to home kensake kudo he is
an aspiring comedian still looking for a
stable career
akira sits separately from other family
members and quietly enjoys his meal when
kentucky politely offers them to attend
a show akira scolds him for not being
able to find a stable career and afford
for his future family then dismisses him
miki gets angry at his father and also
leaves as she does not think her father
knows what is best for her
akio only watches the conflict quietly
unsure of what to do
akira reaches for his game console to
find comfort in playing final fantasy
but his wife bans him she forbids him to
play games until the conflict with miki
is resolved but then he negotiates to
play for an hour
he wants to defeat another enemy named
titan but fails to do it in the one-hour
time span
through game avatars akio advises him to
get to know his daughter's boyfriend
better because just like in-game they
can only defeat enemies if they truly
know and understand them akira takes
that advice and goes to kensake's show
miki is surprised to find her father
there but is glad that he finds kencike
as a funny and hardworking man
she reconciles with him after the show
telling the success to akio in the game
akira also expresses his intention to
get to know the world more especially
outside of work because his life was
defined only by work
akio suggests they beat the hardest
enemy in final fantasy twintania he also
tells the plan directly to satomi at
work so they can work together to defeat
it to his surprise he finds his dad in
front of his door one evening asking if
he can help teach him how to beat twin
tania because he does not want to let
his online friends down
he even asks him to sit down beside him
during the battle but that would blow up
his cover as he is unable to play his
avatar at the same time so he makes an
excuse
miki is glad to see his brother and
father interacting more closely although
there is still awkwardness between them
the battle with twin tania is scheduled
at 9 00 pm on a friday with akio
planning to tell his identity to his
father after the battle
when the day comes akira suddenly feels
unwell and is rushed to a hospital
akio's director just expresses his
intention to move akira for an overseas
business project when akio receives a
call from his family and is forced to
leave work early they find out that
akira has brain damage that requires
surgery which causes him to suddenly
quit his job
they then discover that akira is missing
from his hospital room
akio immediately rushes home but miki
calls to inform him that their dad is
not at home
satomi then calls asking where he is
because the battle with twin tania is
about to begin in indy jones akira's
avatar is too excited
akio deduces that his dad is at an
internet cafe for their battle with
twintania he knows he should be looking
for his father instead of playing games
but akira insists that they should all
be excited to defeat twin tania so he
plays along after a tough battle they
win then akio bravely tells akira that
he should come home because his family
is waiting at home
akira then knows that akio is one of his
online final fantasy friends then cries
happy tears he then agrees to take the
surgery because he believes that if he
can defeat twin tania and other tough
enemies at final fantasy he can defeat
other life challenges as well especially
with support from his family
years later akira survived the surgery
and has been on his console since early
morning which only makes miki and her
mother shake their heads he
enthusiastically plays final fantasy to
interact with akio who currently works
abroad in singapore
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching